the FBI admits it failed to follow up on
a tip last month that Florida high
school shooter Nicholas Cruz was
planning an attack the Justice
Department says it is launching an
investigation Florida Republican
Governor Rick Scott is calling on FBI
director Christopher Ray to resign
the first funerals for the victims were
held today tonight we're learning more
about some of them senior correspondent
Rick Leventhal is at Broward health
North in Pompano Beach tonight mourners
gather at the Star of David Memorial
Gardens in North Lauderdale to remember
and bury one of the youngest victims of
Wednesday's Florida High School shooting
Alissa al-hadith was just 14 years old a
student and soccer player a bright light
lost forever this is so smart beautiful
creative outgoing she always wants to go
to the next events and next activity she
loved everybody trusted everybody she
was an amazing soccer player let's
continue to pray every day every night
Thursday night thousands gathered for a
vigil near the high school holding
candles and signs many openly sobbing as
the names of the victims were read
speakers included the father of 14 year
old Jamie Guttenberg
Jamie was such a special kid all of the
kids here are what is unfathomable is
Jamie took a bullet and is dead
I I don't know what I do next
my wife is home we are broken freshmen
hailey Betancourt who heard the gunfire
Wednesday spoke to martha maccallum
after attending the vigil I was crying
the whole time but it was it was really
hard to take in because you you hear all
your friends names and then I lost eight
friends
three of the Dead were teachers or
coaches including Aaron Feist who worked
with the football team and as a security
guard being remembered as a hero for
using his body to shield students from
the bullets it's actually really hard to
talk about coach right now the hardest
part will be driving through the front
gates and not seeing coach Feist sitting
there giving me a thumbs up or making me
stop to roll the window down
and saying that you know he cares about
me or have a good day at school or get
my get my stuff done because I'm a
knucklehead or something like that
meanwhile at this very moment like the
president's motorcade is arriving here
at Broward health North Medical Center
we're told that the President and First
Lady will be meeting with doctors and
other health professionals here who
helped save lives there are three
victims still being treated here at
Broward health North - and fair
condition one in critical but that
patient said to be improving three
others shooting victims are still
recovering at Broward Medical in Fort
Lauderdale one was released from there
earlier today Mike the son of a
sheriff's deputy who is said to be
recovering and healing from this point
on at home again the president arriving
here at Broward Health at this moment to
meet with doctors and other medical
healthcare professionals Mike our Rick
Leventhal live in Pompano Beach tonight
Rick many thanks